oh my god Candace are you crying what  are you drunk  what no that's my guess how much have  you had this is water oh right there  yeah this is a place of business  oh so I have a date tonight with this  one guy but then this other guy texted  me today and wants to go out tonight -  so like one's really I'm actually just  here for an interview do you guys  usually drink on Wednesday morning do  you think Jordans gonna hide you're like  you must have your drunk goggles on well  he's nice and all but what no look at  the way he's treating that peppermint  pattie it's like it's doing a good job  at it you know did you just find those  and now you're eating them yeah they're  not your chips though  Kubo carry this you can sing like a  drunk girl  yeah we're dancing like drunk girls  Ricky you're dancing like a drunk girl  have you been drinking Kansas no why why  does everyone say I'm doing my how many  people do I'm eating